قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها
اضطرت لتدمير مواقع تابعه للجيش الاوكراني
بعد قصفها مواقع روسيه عقبه دخول الهدنه
حيز التنفيذ وكانت موسكو اعلنت هدنه
بمناسبه اعياد الميلاد لمده 36 ساعه تبدا
منتصف نهار الجمعه وقد رفضت كيب الهدنه
بينما اكدت واشنطن وانقره انا الحربه تمر
بمرحله حرجه وانها مرشحه للتسعيد في
الفتره المقبله
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله اعلان موسكو
التزامتها بهدنه لا تقبلها كيف وما مواجهه
الحجج التي ساقها المشككون في دوافعها
لاعلان تلك الهدنه كذلك ما هي الشواهد
التي تستند اليها اوكرانيا وحلفاءها في
الحديث عن مرحله حرجه تمر بها الحرب
لتوقع
اشتداديها خلال المرحله المقبله
اخيرا ما هي المسارات التي يمكن ان تاخذها
الحرب في اوكرانيا في ظل استمرار كياب
وحلفائها في التخندق لمواجهه بوتن
[موسيقى]
على اكثر من جبهه في خطوط التماس الممتده
شرقي وجنوبي اوكرانيا توالت الانباء عن
قصف الروسيا اوكرانيا
اعلنت استجابه لنداء اطلقته الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه الروسيه فبعد وقت وجيزا من
نداء الكنيسه طلب الرئيس الروسي بلادي
بيركب من جيشه مساء الخميس بدا وقت في
اطلاق النار على كل خط المواجهه في
اوكرانيا اعتبارا من منتصف نهار الجمعه
ولمده 36 ساعه
القوه الاوكرانيه الى التقيد بهذه الهدنه
لتمكين اتباع الطائفه الارثوذكسيه من حضور
احتفالات ليله الميلاد بحسب تقويم الكنيسه
الشرقيه والمشاركه في الصلوات دعوه سارعت
كيف الى رفضها والتشكيك في دوافعها فقد
اتهم الرئيس مرسي القياده الروسيه اثرها
في محاوله استخدامه عيد الميلاد غطاءا
في تقدم قوات بلاده في الجبهه الشرقيه
واضاف ان انسحاب الجيش الروسي من كامل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه هو الطريق الوحيد لوقف
الحرب ووقف خسائر الارواح
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا
وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه السابق من موسكو
معنا ستانلس
البحث في العلاقات الدوليه ومن عمان معنى
اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اهلا بكم جميعا الى ما وراء
الخبر
وابدا بعد معك سيدكم
لماذا ترفض كيف الهدنه
التي
تصدر ليس فقط
ومعنا له ان عدد الهدن المعلنه في 2014
الى 2019
بالعشرات ولكنها لم تحترم اطلاقا بشكل
التي اقترحت في السيف الماضي ايضا رفضتها
رفضت من قبل مجلس الامن همم في مجال من
قبل السيد الرئيس وهو رئيس
الروسيه في المجلس لانه قال لي اسمك ايه
فائده من وجوده في حين انهم فقط يريدون من
ان تستسلم في هذه الان اليوم هناك رغبه من
جانب ال ال الروسي لاعادهم الى اعاده
تجميع القواتهم لتحقق بعض الفوائد ولكن
هذا لن ينجح ان الطريق الحقيقيه توصل
للسلام هي نقل قوات روسيه من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه
يقول ضيفنا من كيف ان كيف ترفضه ان اا
الامر ليس جديا ولكن في الواقع بعد ان
اثرت علامات الاستفهام الكثيره بشان طرح
الهدنه رفضتها مباشره ولكن
موسكو تمسكت بها
وهنا السؤال ما دلاله تمسك
موسكو بهدنا رفضتها كيف فورا
ربما حيله
تواصليه ربما كان من
التمارسه بشكل افضل
للحيلوله دون محاوله
الاستفاده من ان روسيا
ستحاول تعزيز سيطرتها على المناطق التي
استطاعت السيطره عليها ربما في الامر
محاوله من جانب بوتن ان يبدي اماطه حسن
النيه تجاهها السيد اردوغان الرئيس التركي
يا بلد المهمه
لروسيا الان من منظور
اقتصادي ومنصور صادرات النفط والغاز
وبالتاكيد تركيا ستكون بدها الدول التي
ستلعب دور الوسيط في المراحل النهائيه من
هذا النزاع لهذا السبب قرر بوتن القيام
بهذه العمليه
طبعا في روسيا قبوله يعني
سيد متراكم
لطلب الكنيسه كما قيل رسميا
لعبه دورا كبيره
لا ينظر اليه من منظور يتصور دينيا ابدا
الكنيسه مجرد اداه تم استخدامها وهذا ليس
غريبا
فلم المناسبات الدينيه تم استخدامها في
السابق وبدات وكانها مجرد ادوات تخدم
اغراض السياسيه
بغض النظر عن الاسباب التي يبدو انه تبحث
عنها لطرح الهدنه ما هي قراءتك اولا لطرح
له والتمسك بها بعد ان رفضت بهذا الشكل
يعني اعتقد ان طرح الهدنه حمل عده مضامين
وعده رسائل والرسائل موجهه للدعاء للشعب
الروسي
والشعب الاوكراني بنفس الوقت
ورساله موجهه للجانب التركي
ورساله موجهه للعالم
كي الان احتفالات الميلاد حسب التقويم
الشرقي وبالتالي جل السكان في كلا البلدين
يتبعون همم
ذلك
الكنيسه الشرقيه وبالتالي همم سيكون هناك
رغبه لدى المواطن ان يحتفل في هذه
المناسبات السنويه اذا هذه رساله للداخل
رساله الى اوكرانيا الى همم تركيا لماذا
الرئيس التركي قبل 24 ساعه من اعلان
الهنديه تحدث صراحه ان يكون هناك وقف
اطلاق نار ولو من جانب واحد وكانت تعليق
في ذلك اليوم انه لم يحدد الجانب
المعني هل هو الجانب الروسي من ام الجانب
الاوكراني رساله الى العالم في ظل همم
التصاعد المحموم وعمليات التقصير الاموال
58 مليار تزويد بدبابه
الياتر واا
الاليات الامريكيه اذا دعيني اقول رساله
للعالم انه هناك نزوع روسي نحو همم
المفاوضات نحو تحقيق انفراجا لتكون هذه
على غرار مباراه كره السله في الصين وما
بين امريكا
بلا شك هذا له دلاله
نعم
يعني لا استطيع ان اقول المنتصر اقول الذي
خلقك انجازاته ميدانيه
يعني هذا ما نسال عنه
ليكن ما يشاء لكن الواقع يقول غير ذلك في
بدايه الحمل في الشهر الاول تم السيطره
على مساحات واسعه استطاعت اوكرانيا ان
تستعيد 54% من مساحه الاراضي التي تم
السيطره عليها وتعرض الى ثلاثه انت كاسات
وبالتالي همم تم قصف جسر كرش تم تدمير همم
السفينه الرئيسيه مسكافا ثم قتل همم مئات
الجنود قبل خمسه ايام خسر ثلاثه مناطق اذا
دعيني اقول الواقع الميداني لا ينسج مع
التصريح همم الروسي همم السيد هارشينكو
كيف لم تكتفي فقط بالرفض بل انها اتهمت
بوتن بانه يستغل اعياد الميلاد لوقف
التقدم في الشرق
على ماذا تستند
نحن
كيف ان هذه المبادرات تطلق هذا يجري عندما
هناك مشاكل
الرئيسي اما فكره
الاستجابه للطلب طلب من رئيس التركي قد
تساعد لاحقا ولكنني اعتقد انهم اكثر همم
هذا في هذا الوقت بالذات
وفي يوم راس السنه الجديده تعرضنا لهجوم
من قبل مسيراتتين وصواريخ في مدينه كيف
كان الناس يحتفلون بالسنه الجديده
الذي كان يستهدف التحتيه المدنيه اذا ليس
هناك اي ثقه في اي شيء تعرضه روسيا حاليا
لان كسر الثقه بدا ليس انس قبل يومين بل
قبل السنوات عندما ااا معاهدات الفوتيهم
حسام التراضي وسياده اوكرانيا
كل ذلك عهود والمعاهدات نقضت وبالتالي
الاول
بروسيا وهذا يبدا اولا بسحب القوات روسيه
من اراضينا
استعاده الثقه
في الدوافع الهدنه الروسيه تجاوز كيف حتى
الى حلفائها هدنا قللت من شانها ايضا لندن
وبرلين التان اكدتا انها لن تخدم افاق
السلام بالطلبتان بدلا عنها بانسحاب
النهائي للقوات الروسيه من اوكرانيا
واشنطن اعتبرتها مجرد محاوله لالتقاط
الانفاس لنسمه
ايش معنى كلمه
عن التعليق على اي شيء يقوله بوتين ومن
المذهل انه لم يتبرع عن قصف كنائس ومدارس
ومستشفيات في الخامس والعشرين ديسمبر
الماضي قبل راس السنه
واقف
طبعا يعتبروا ان الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه
الروسيه هي
الطائفه المسيحيه الاهم من وجهه نظره في
روسيا وفي اوكرانيا كذلك لكنني لا اعتقد
ان احد يصدق او صدق باندان قطار سيتوقف
الان وقد يكون اعلان الهدنه من جانب واحد
واكرانيا استمرت قصف المواقع الروسيه
والروسيه بالطبع كانت
لهذا السبب لم لا يمكن ايقاف الحرب الجانب
الواحد لكن
كحيله تواصليه اعلاميه او دعائيه ربما
كانت محاوله جيده لكن حسب نظري لم تلعب
بشكل جيد
اه حتى داخل روسيا لم تلاقي قبوله انه
وخاصه
في لدى الوطنيين الروس لهذا السبب القصف
سيستمر ربما لاحقا اردوغان واخرين
سيتذكرون ان بوتن استجاب لمحاولات الطلبه
التوسط ربما بعد سته اشهر من الان او شيء
من ذلك وعندما تستطيع روسيا اعاده تجميع
قواتها طبعا هذا الذي يتم في غضون 36 ساعه
لان القصف مستمر ولا يمكن ايصال تعزيزات
عسكريه بطرق امنه الموضوع هو سياسي
هل هذا يسجل مع الصوره التي رسمها بوتن
لنفسه منذ بدايه الحرب
يقول انها ربما حين لا يريد ان يظهر بمظهر
المتجاوب مع الوساطات يريد ان يرسل وانت
قلتها
للداخل بانه يهتم يحترم اعياد الميلاد
ولكن فعليا
هذه الصوره الحديث عن النصر والوعود
الكثيره الان ان يظهر بهذه الصوره 36 ساعه
والطرف الاخر يرفضها وهو يتمسك بها
الا على المدى البعيد والمنظور العسكري
والاستراتيجي الا يمكن ان يعد هذا همم او
ساتركك انت تحدد ماذا يحدد من هذا الموضوع
يعني انت اشرتي الى ان الجانب المنتصر قبل
قليل وانا قلت هذا هو ما يقوله وليس ما
يتحدث به الميدان
الواقع الميداني لا يعكس التصريحات
بصوره كبيره جدا في الجانب الروسي وبصوره
اقل في الجانب الاوكراني كل الجانبين يضخم
من الانجازات الان الجانب الروسي حقيقه
اذا اردنا ان نتحدث عن الامد لهذه الحرب
الزمن ليس في صالح القوات الروسيه وقد
يستغرب الكثير هذا الكلام نعم اللغه
العدديه ولغه الارقام تميل لصالح روسيا
بينما لغه الميدان واداره المعركه وتوظيف
القدرات كمين لصالح اوكرانيا الذيل
الاداري او امكانيه امداد العمليات تميل
لجانب الصالح لصالح الجانب الاوكراني
الجسر الجوي الغربي امريكا ودول حلف
الناتو
20 دوله دعيني اقول ان لم يستطع حزم
المعركه في الربيع القادم وهذا ما يسعى
جاهدا له ستكون بدايه الهزيمه لقوات روسيه
وهذا ما ارجعه وهذا ما يقودني ايضا للفقره
التاليه فالحديث عن الهدنه تحول للمفارقه
الى مناسبه للحديث عن حرج المرحله التي
تمر بها لدى كيب وبعد حلفائها الرئيسيين
اندراير ماك مدير مكتب الرئيس الاوكرانيا
يقول ان الشتاء الحالي والربيع المقبل
سيشكلان نقطه مهمه لتقدم القوات
الاوكرانيه على الارض واضاف انما سماه
احداثا رئيسيه تنتظر الاوكرانيين وانا
نهايتها ستكون استعاده جميع الاراضي
الاوكرانيات هذا مقاله
في ذات الاتجاه الرئيس جو بايدن الذي قال
من جانبه ان الحرب في اوكرانيا تمر بما
سماه مرحله حرجه مجددا وان على بلاده عمل
كل ما بوسعها لمساعده الاوروبيه
على مقاومه العدوان الروسي وروسيا لا
تحاول الابطال الحرب وانما تستمر فيها بكل
همجيه
سيد هاشمكم على ماذا تستند اكيف في حديثها
عن شتاء وربيع ساخنين
ينتهيان باستعاده اراضيهما حسب المسؤول
الاوكراني
ستكون سهل القوات الاوكرانيه ما قاله
الرئيس وغيره من المسؤولين هو ان لا
نستطيع ان نوقف الحرب ولا ان حر كل
اراضينا لو لدينا قوات مسلحه متفاهميه جدا
وان الشعب يدعم ما نحاول ان نحققه خلال
هذه الاشهر ان القصه قصه مديرنا وبنانا
التحيه في الطاقه
بدي الا تعزيز قوته ومقاومه الشعب
الاوكراني
فمن الذي كانوا حريصيننا على
على
التاثر بالحار بالعفو بالجو السائل بارد
وقله الماء غادروا بلاد هؤلاء لم تن
وبالتالي نحن الان لدينا
[موسيقى]
العزيمه مستمر قائمه من قبل المدنين
اكثر من 50 دوله
تشارك في ما الذي
مباراه فرنسا
المتحدث باسمها رجح ارتفاع وتيره
المواجهات في الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
خلال الاشهر المقبله واضاف ان ذلك يعني
المزيد من الموت والدمار
الى اي حد تتفق موسكو بان الحرب تمر بفتره
حرجه
وانها تتجه الى التصعيد خلال الفتره
المقبله
موقع
ممكن ان يكون هناك تصعيد
النظري روسيا
واقرانيا كل منهما يحاول بسطه سيطرته على
الارض لكن اعتقد الناس نصل الى حاله من
التوازن وادراك اوكرانيا
استعاده كل اراضيها وخاصه شبه جزيره الكرم
هم قالوا انهم سيدخلون شبه جزيره القرم في
الشتاء ومره على الشتاء شهران ولا يوجد
دليل على قدرته القوات العسكريه الاكرانيه
على دخولها الى شبه جزيره القرم اذا ممكن
ان نقول ان هنا مبالغه من جانبهم ايضا
هناك حدود
لحجم الدعم العسكري من العالم الغربي الى
اوكراني على سبيل لو سمحت لم يبقى لي الا
دقيقه اريد ان اسال فايز الدويري هنا هل
هذا الدعم لا محدود الذي يبدو ان الغرب
يقدمه لكيف وتصريحات كيف همم يفسر الى اين
يعني يعتقد ان تتجه الامور انت كيف تراها
58 مليار 40 مليار من امريكا و18 مليار من
الدول الاوروبيه وهذا يغطي الاحتياجات
القتاليه لعام 2023 وبالتالي الحسابات
تسير على ان هذه الحرب قد تنتهي في نهايه
عام 2003
وهي تنتهي بنقطه وسطيه لا روسيا تستطيع
حسمها لانه الحزم الروسي يعلن السيطره على
كيف مركز الثقل الاستراتيجي وهي لن تستطيع
وان ارسلت قوات والحسم العسكر الاوكراني
تحرير الاراضي ولن تستطيع فعل ذلك
من عمان شكرا
جزيلا لكم على متابعه هذه الحلقه
[موسيقى]